بالفعل هناك تصريحات
مستمره من قبل مؤسس قوات فاجنر يفغينيا
بروجيجن
يتهم فيها الدفاع الروسيه بالتقصير
بالامدادات العسكريه ان كان البشريه او
حتى
الامداد بالذخيره لكن حقيقه هنا في محور
عشرات الالاف من القذائف والصواريخ
المتنوعه تطلق بشكل يومي على مواقع القوات
الاوكرانيه المتمركزه في عده محاور ربما
يكون
يطلب اسلحه يعني بنوع
خصيصا او معين وترفض الدفاع الروسيه
امداده بهذا النوع لانه يكون ممنوع دوليا
او يعني غير متواجد ما بين ايدي الدفاع
الروسيه بالفعل المعارك مستمره وقويه
وتشهد شراسه كبيره على جميع المحاور ان
كان افديف كمارنكا
هذه المعارك تشهد تقدم للقوات الروسيه
وضخمه اهم النقاط ايضا تتقدم فيها قوات
فاجنر كل هذا التقدم ينتظر انجاز كامل
بالسيطره على احدى المدن كما كان في
سوليدار على سبيل المثال وهذا ما يتوق
اليه الجانب الروسي في ذات الوقت تدافع
اوكرانيا عن مدينه باخموت لدرجه ان توقف
الانتصارات الروسيه المتكرره منذ انطلاق
هذا العام